la justicia para las mujeres aquí llega
con décadas de retraso un tribunal
condenó a 30 años de prisión a cinco ex
paramilitares por violar a más de 30
indígenas durante la guerra civil en la
década de los 80 un crimen de lesa
humanidad y yo me si me dejaron 25 día
en este camente y todo es el 25 de este
mes violaron sexualmente los militares y
algunas patrulleros también
entonces por eso este ahora pues
comenzamos en el 2011 buscando la
justicia y está ahora estamos y queremos
que se haga justicia que se condenan las
personas que nos decían el daño las
víctimas de la etnia chií fueron abusada
repetidamente en su pueblo natal rabinal
y en un puesto militar de la comunidad
maya entre 1981 y 1985 pero no fue hasta
hace una década cuando se decidieron a
denunciar lo sucedido los cinco
condenados formaban parte de las
patrullas de autodefensa civil un
organismo paramilitar controlado por el
ejército durante el conflicto armado que
dejó más de 245.000 asesinados y
desaparecidos más del 90 por ciento a
manos del gobierno y quedó reflejado que
sí que el estado tiene una
responsabilidad ante la creación de las
patrullas de autodefensa civil aquí la
implementación de la violencia sexual
como una estrategia durante el conflicto
armado interno que buscaba no sólo
destruir el cuerpo de las mujeres sino
también de instruir a comunidades
enteras esta es la segunda vez que un
tribunal guatemalteco condena
responsables de abusos contra mujeres
indígenas durante la guerra civil tras
la condena de dos antiguos soldados en
2016 por entre otras cosas
esclavizar sexualmente a 11 indígenas
historias que las víctimas están
decididas a que salgan a la luz